whew
welcome back Merle thank you it's great
to see you again nice to be here you got
some more some new ink yeah I think I've
gotten like four or five new pieces
since the last time I was here
at least a couple on my
beautiful face head whatever you want to
call it
so I don't want to spend the whole time
here talking about Gigi and G you know
all the ins and outs of Gigi because I
think you're an interesting character
as well
um but but tell me about how you guys
grew up how are you as children well I
mean you know we grew up in the log
cabin in New Hampshire
um very isolated from pretty much
everybody we didn't have we didn't
really have neighbors because we lived
on an rfd3 road so we lived in a small
town between two other small towns
so
Neighbors
were
few and far between and kids to play
with zero so me and my brother basically
had to entertain ourselves
um
we played Sports we played we played a
lot of baseball we played Army you know
we had like walkie talkies and stuff
like that and uh and we lived like
in a pretty rural area so we were always
off into the woods or whatever just
exploring you know just doing [__] were
there signs that Gigi was
his signs of his adult personality even
as a kid no I mean well you know
one time he did take a a milk bottle now
back in the day you know the Milkman
used to deliver your milk in a milk
bottle okay
so one day my brother took the milk
bottle and [__] smashed it over my
head and I don't know that you can well
you probably can't see the scar now it
was I had a little scar in my head
forever I guess if you know where it is
you might see it but it's probably
covered up by Tattoos by now but yeah so
I guess you know of course I was
bleeding all over the place and my poor
mom was like you know stressing out over
it but I ended up Surviving so how big a
factor was the poverty you guys grew up
in
um it was pretty bad I mean we we lived
in a
three-room Log Cabin
uh no running water
so we had to go to a well to get water
we didn't have a bathtub we didn't have
a shower we didn't have anything like
that so we basically took sponge baths
in the sink you know when we were kids
and stuff like that so uh yeah we didn't
uh and we didn't have very many toys
um
a big big day out would be to go into
town and you know buy some Penny Candy
and [__] like that I mean literally
we really had nothing you know yeah
growing up like that color's your your
whole life after that you know when you
grow up like that and you finally get to
a point where you have a little bit of
success and you have a little bit of
money it's like
you know people you kind of become a
hoarder I I guess I'm kind of guilty of
being a hoarder you know when it comes
to money and [__] my friends are always
like well you got this money but you
never spend it you know and I'm like
well
you know when you grew up like I did
you don't want to go back there ever
again you know so
you you know I mean I've been lucky
enough to be fairly successful and you
know I have a roof over my head I'm not
missing any meals I you know I don't
really
buy a lot of things I'm not really a
materialistic person you're married
right I like to collect stuff you know
I'm a collector no I've been married
twice but you're not married now yeah no
I'm not twice was enough for me I don't
want to be a three-time loser two-time
loser's enough you know how do you and
your brother get started in music
um well
we saw the Beatles on The Ed Sullivan
Show in 1964. yeah so
that's basically how we got started I
mean other than the fact that my mom and
dad you know had records like uh you
know I had Johnny Cash and
and Willie Nelson and Hank Williams and
you know the stuff like that it's kind
of what we grew up on was country you
know
and then uh after seeing the Beatles and
after you know the whole British
Invasion thing in the 60s and uh
stuff like that that's basically how we
got started you know
and seeing your your brothers I guess
his drug was mostly alcohol
yeah I mean he would do anything he gave
him right but watching that is that
change the path of your life in terms of
those kind of substances uh well you
know I've been around
countless junkies and that I've been in
bands with junkies
um I've seen you know
musicians that I you know
idolized or you know looked up to when I
was young you know saw what happened to
their careers and how they [__] up
their
lives and or died from overdoses or
whatever so you know I never really uh I
mean I did Coke in the 80s and you know
[__] like that I but I never really got
into anything addicting you know uh
never did heroin I've never done heroin
in my life yeah which is what killed
Gigi yeah so you know why would I want
to do something that killed my brother
you know it's like
but yeah which of the bands that you've
been in has been your favorite
my favorite
uh
I would have to say malpractice would be
one of them because that was the second
band me and my brother had together
and it was really the first band that we
had together that
we actually like went out and played
like went on the road you know I mean it
was just we were like a Maine New
Hampshire Vermont you know New England
band
but you know we get in the van every
weekend and we'd travel to Maine or
wherever we were playing and and set up
and play for the weekend and go home so
it was like
our first experience of actually
being in a band where you get paid and
you get to travel and you get to play in
front of people you'd never seen before
you know
so
that would be one of them of course my
second choice would be thrills
which was the band that I moved to
Boston
to play with in 1978
um
Johnny Angel had put an ad in the
Boston Phoenix
looking for
a bass player and a drummer and he came
up to New Hampshire drove up to New
Hampshire and auditioned us and we
passed the audition uh but at that point
Gigi didn't want to play drums anymore
so he bowed out and I moved to Boston uh
summer of 78 I was like 22 years old
and
I went from 1977 when I was still living
in New Hampshire listening to cassette
tapes of The Dead Boys The Ramones
Blondie The Sex Pistols all that
first second wave of punk rock you know
I went from listening to those bands to
playing in a band that was opening for
those bands I mean we opened for The
Dead Boys we opened for the Ramones
the cars the you know Johnny Thunders
David Johansen uh New York you know New
York Dolls and stuff like that we opened
for a lot of really
uh
popular bands at the time you mentioned
last time that was your favorite
favorite time of your life it was one it
was definitely one of them because I you
know that's where I really learned
about rock and roll you know I mean I
was living
it was it was 1978 so it's kind of still
the first wave of punk you know and uh
we were
living in Boston there was like
literally three or four
Punk clubs there was a Paradise Theater
which was the was the 500 seater where
the Ramones and bands like that would
play
and being one of the headline weekend
headline bands that the Thrills was we
got to open for a lot of those bands but
we also got to see bands at like the
place called the rat the ratskeller
lounge which was Z it was the cbgbs of
Boston you know and everybody played the
rat I mean
you could see like the police you know
would come to the rat and play in front
of like two or three hundred people and
then the next time you saw them they
were playing Boston Garden in front of
20 000 people you know but we got to see
all these bands
in front of like 100 or 200 people you
know so it was like a magical time
in music
uh I don't know what the [__] I'm saying
no it was it was a magical time to be
able to you know listen to good College
radio so you'd listen to College radio
and your friends were like the DJs
because you knew everybody in the scene
because the scene was small at that
point
of course
as it got more popular
it got more crowded and then it became
more you know
kind of sucked but but it was still cool
you know but uh
it was it was just fun because it was
like a family of fans a small little
family of fans that were discovering all
these new bands through College radio
and you'd hear them on the radio and
you'd go to their shows and they'd be
like you know two three hundred people
at the most you know and and of course
all the bands that were coming in from
New York uh you know with different
members from like the New York Dolls we
played with Johnny Saunders uh we opened
for David Johansson at the paradise when
he did that live album uh we played with
all the different factions of those
different bands
and it was exciting for us because we
were we were big fans of all that stuff
like
a few years before that you know so
so yeah that would probably be I mean
that's got to be right up there you know
I mean of course playing with my brother
in the murder junkies would be number
one you know but
um
Thrills was definitely uh one of my
favorite periods of my life for sure I
was young you know uh didn't have
anything to do we've worked shitty jobs
we'd go to we you know everybody in the
band would have crappy jobs we'd go to
our jobs and then we'd skip work and
we'd you know stay out I mean we stayed
all all night back in those days you
know the the club would end at like two
o'clock and then somebody would have a
party and you'd a lot of times you'd be
walking home as the sun was coming up
and all the you know robots were heading
off to work you'd just be heading home
to sleep you know so uh
but yeah it was uh it was a really
amazing time in my life yeah I think the
fact that you
we're doing it for the love of it rather
than for the money oh yeah well yeah and
I mean that's the thing too I mean we
you know our rent like I lived with a
photographer guy
we had a one bedroom apartment right
I lived in the living room he lived in
the bedroom I think our rent was like a
hundred and some odd dollars a month
each you know and and that was hard to
pay even back then you know
because we had shitty jobs that we would
go to and then we would skip work all
the time because we'd stay out late and
we'd have our friends call in for us oh
we're sick today you know after uh
multiple times of missing work you'd
lose your job
but
on a good weekend
we could pull in like
a hundred dollars a piece
at a gig so if we played the rat like on
a weekend we'd make like four or five
hundred dollars after the rap [__]
door people [__] skimmed the [__]
take you know
um
we would make enough money to pay our
rent but we never had any money you know
and we were lucky because we got the
benefits of being
the band that we were so we never had to
pay to get into clubs we always got into
clubs for free and a lot of times your
friends would buy you drinks and [__] I
used to drink and do a lot of like
Valium and [__] stuff like that I my
friends would call me the next day and
tell me what a [__] [__] I was the
night before
and then we'd go and do the same [__]
thing again the next day you know
so it was the shock value of what you
guys were doing with Gigi
a way to kind of get some Acclaim and
get some following
or was it just the way he was oh it was
just the way he was I mean Gigi Gigi was
a self-promoter right from the [__]
beginning
he would do an interview with somebody
that had a Zine that got 20 people let's
look at it he didn't care
how big the publication was or what it
was for he would do an interview he
would do anything to get his name you
know it's funny people are really funny
because they think oh Gigi would have
hated that Gigi would have hated having
you know a doll of him oh Gigi would
have hated having a bobble head Gigi
loved that [__] Gigi [__] lived for
getting his name his face his picture
whatever the [__] it was he loved that
[__] these [__] douche [__] today
that weren't even alive when my brother
was [__] they were [__] in their
[__] diapers when my brother was
[__] on stage and they think they
know all about my brother they're a
bunch of [__] [__] [__] you you
stupid [__]
yeah his personality really kind of just
was what it was and it wasn't never
really yeah I mean you know I mean like
I say he didn't start out like you know
[__] on stage and beating people up
it was a slow progression uh that
started with him flipping tables and
just you know
just getting you know rolling on the
ground and getting all dirty and you
know uh but would he ever say afterwards
like that was [__] crazy what I did
today or anything like that oh you know
every show pretty much after every show
like that was the best show I think we
ever did you know I heard that night
after night after night that was the
greatest show we ever did you know or
yeah I mean but but it wasn't like
something that he planned on doing it
just the adrenaline when he got on stage
it just whatever was going on that night
whatever was in his head whoever was
[__] with him or whatever uh whatever
mood he was in he just went off on a
tangent you know and you didn't know
from one night to the next what he was
going to do you know
I mean we we had we had a show
in
Joplin Missouri
and uh
we were borrowing you know we were
borrowing gear from bands because we
didn't bring our own equipment after the
first time we went out in 91 and brought
all of our equipment with us we decided
that was the end of that because getting
out of a venue quickly when you're
trying to carry amps and drums and all
that [__] that wasn't working so we
stopped bringing equipment we don't even
bring equipment to this day use rent no
we make the promoters
have to hire a band that will let us use
their entire back line really yeah so we
don't travel with equipment the only
thing we travel with is merchandise
but like your your guitar merchandise
stuff to sell yeah and guitars yeah we
have our guitars and that's it but the
answer the amps and everything is are
supplied for us you know really so so we
would we were playing this show in
Joplin Missouri and uh
obviously we were borrowing the band's
equipment that was on stage and
Gigi started pacing in the dressing room
and uh
when she when Gigi started pacing Gigi
wanted to do stuff and he wanted to do
it right away like
he didn't like to wait for anything if
you weren't ready when Gigi was he'd
leave you behind
you know that's why I knew that that's
why I had to get it together to get a
bandwidth because
whether I was his brother or not if
somebody else came along with the band
he was going to go with them and and I
understood that you know but
so this band's playing and playing and
playing and they won't stop playing and
Gigi's pacing and pacing and pacing and
I'm like this is not going to end well
you know in the meantime we'd already
gotten paid for the gig
so I had the money in my pocket and uh
all of a sudden Gigi comes tearing out
of the dressing room
s up on stage
and tackles the singer knocks him into
the drum set knocks all the equipment
over
and says you guys are [__] done
wow
obviously that didn't go over very well
with the band that was letting us use
their equipment right so
um
so that was out of the out of the
question so in the meantime
I knew we had the money so I told Evan
our driver I said Evan go get the van
and everybody just very discreetly get
together and when the van gets here it's
going to all get in the van tear off you
know and that's what we did with the
money yeah it was people still talk
about that story
you know
but yeah it was Gigi challenging to be
in a bandwidth
well yeah I mean
well I mean we had a lot of great times
believe me I wouldn't have I wouldn't
have done it more than once if I wasn't
enjoying it but
enjoying it was also
enduring it and enduring meaning you
know Gigi would stay up all night
drinking
and you know even if you gave him a
valium or or something to you know help
him sleep he would still be up for hours
taking forever to fall asleep and of
course Dino didn't have to drive or do
anything because he was incapable you
know
he'd stay up with Gigi and party and you
know they'd be naked in bed together and
like you know sticking things up each
other's butt and [__] I mean you know
like just being silly you know I've
heard I've heard crazy stories about
Dino Yeah well yeah there's a lot of
crazy stories about you know I mean
what's the craziest thing you know give
us a little taste of what I mean crazy
this so you know what there's a whole
dean of stories there's a whole Dino
episode or you need to just interview
Dino for sure and I'm sure some of you
people are going to ask you that but
every time we can arrange that maybe
yeah so uh dino wow Dino loves the women
um
he can't keep his hands off a woman I
mean he's got a you know anytime I bring
a woman around Dino I tell Dino I'll
tell the girl first I'll be Dino might
come up to you he might try to give you
a kiss he might try to squeeze on you
you know
you deal with it however you want to
deal with it you know and I'll tell Dino
ahead of time don't [__] with this girl
this is my girl you know but
Dino just loves to squeeze boobs so
we had a gig
this was post Gigi this was 90 95. we
were on tour
we were playing down in Florida
and we were playing in a strip mall
where the venue was and there was a
record store right next to the venue
right
so we go into the record store just you
know kill time right and it was a
mother-daughter
working together I think it was a mother
daughter I don't know an older woman and
a younger girl
so we're just you know thumbing through
records and stuff and all of a sudden we
hear
scream
well you look up and Dino squeezing the
boobs of this young girl behind the
counter of the record store the mother
or older woman whoever she was was
[__] screaming and yelling get the
what the [__] is wrong with you get the
[__] out of my store I'm gonna call the
[__] cops so of course we bolted
right away and we basically left the
area
for a few hours because
we couldn't go back because the venue
was right there but we had to wait for
the record store to close so we could go
back to the venue and
I mean nothing really happened to him
but uh
there's been a lot of close calls with
Dino and stuff like that so you'll have
to connect me yeah yeah
But but so so yeah traveling with
Gigi and Dino definitely quite
challenging uh because like I say they
would stay up and party all night and if
we were all in one hotel room then there
was nobody getting any sleep you know
and me and Bill
our guitar player we did all the driving
and it wasn't like it is today where you
can drive from point A to point B in
three or four hours
you know like normal touring bands book
shows
where they don't have to drive more than
five or six hours to get to a show right
but back in those days
it was hard enough to get shows with
Gigi to begin with and
having him and me booking shows together
was a bad idea because
we would literally some some days we'd
drive like 10 hours to get to a show you
know and or well the good thing was we
didn't we weren't able to play every
single night either
because GG just couldn't
couldn't withstand that kind of abuse to
himself and we just couldn't get that
many shows I mean I'm sure we would have
played more shows if we could have got
them but a lot of times we ended up
playing the show having a couple of days
off
because we had long drives to get to
another show so we could go on the road
for a month and play like two or three
weeks of shows
yeah now we go on the road for six weeks
our coming tours like a six week tour
we've only got like two days off
so really uh but yeah it was it was a
lot of uh driving and being tired but
you know you're you're adrenaline and
your momentum and just the fact that
you're having fun
kind of and you're still young enough to
be able to I mean not that we were young
enough we were [__]
90 90 it was like what 35 40 years old
at that point do you ever ever have to
worry about Gigi not showing up for a
show
well Gigi I always showed up because we
had him I mean we we brought him to the
show so you know I mean he wouldn't get
lost in yeah no he wouldn't no he'd he
basically just slept all day I mean
he basically took the front you know he
had the passenger seat in the front and
he would be like you know just an odd
and off all day long while we were
driving we were nodding off too but we
were driving you know so
but uh yeah so it was it was that and
then
dealing with club Owners promoters
trying to get paid every night and then
dealing with okay you broke this
microphone you smashed this light system
uh you know we're deducting x amount of
money from your pay every night I mean
uh one guy one Cub owner in Texas pulled
a gun on us and [__] said hey I want
some of my money back from tonight's
show and he got some of his money back
you know so [__] like that I had to take
care of all the business
had to take care of trying to keep my
brother from abusing himself so badly
that he couldn't play you know so I was
kind of like the babysitter and then of
course anytime he got in trouble or
ended up in the slammer overnight I had
to be there to bail him out right so or
if he ended up in the hospital which
happened several times while we were on
tour you know uh
so yeah my job was uh not just bass
player and driver I was kind of like in
charge of everything you know what is it
about the
the rock star Persona the you know
because they're you have D you have Gino
and uh do you have Gigi and Dino
and then you I'm sure you've had other
Gangnam uh band members who are
equally problematic
but but along with that is the genius of
being able to perform on stage and
perform this music right this music
singers oh yeah I mean Gigi was a genius
for sure I mean
he was just one of those guys that like
you know could be [__] up all day and
all night and could still write a
[__] you know
Masterpiece of a song you know so I mean
there wasn't much you could do about it
you know I mean you just you either
dealt with it or you or he found
somebody else you know but that
dysfunctional defiant behavior is is
kind of part of the same package is what
creates the yeah the art absolutely so
you know you just gotta you gotta go
along with it you know from
what's up from his from your mom or from
your dad my mom yeah really my mom yeah
my mom is a pretty strong woman
I mean my mom left my dad you know we're
talking what 1965.
with two kids
by herself
trying to take care of us the best year
I mean she did the best she could and
she
raised us to be I mean she raised us
proper I mean we just kind of fell off
the wagon along the way but I mean she
couldn't be there all the time because
she had to work you know so uh but she
was very strong-willed and a lot of
women especially young women she was
[__] she was in her [__]
late 20s I mean when she left my dad a
lot of women back then would never leave
anybody they would rather be in a I mean
not even back then I'm talking about
today I have so many friends that would
love to leave the person there with but
they can't because they can't afford to
be on their own they don't have any
money saved they have no security so
they can't do anything you know my mom
didn't have any of that [__] she just
left because it was the right thing to
do and she wanted to raise us and give
us an opportunity to to do something
that we wanted to do and not be
sheltered and be under the control of
our [__] father you know so
yeah my mom was a strong one you know
so
tell me about the music scene since you
started which was probably the 70s right
yeah I mean the music scene in the 70s
was like I said was the best I mean you
got to see all these uh
up and coming bands or you'd get to see
all the bands that would come into the
U.S for the first time
um
and you know a lot of those bands are
still playing today and people are like
oh you're going to see the dam the dam
just coming back well you know I saw the
Damned on their very first U.S tour in
1978 in front of like 500 people
I mean and I hear they're really still
good but I don't want to go see them in
front of
a couple thousand people now or a few
thousand people I've already seen them
you know I mean I saw one of the reunion
tours in London in the 80s and they were
it was still great
so I mean there's nothing like
being part of something that's the
beginning you know and I mean yeah rock
and roll was starting in the 50s and 60s
but
it it kind of changed in the 70s you
know it got more hard and it wasn't uh
wasn't really the same it was a lot of
just different new bands and
a lot of different different style bands
too you know not everybody was sounding
the same everybody had their own sound
because
everybody was experimenting you know it
wasn't like it is today where a band
will get together and go well you know
this band is really popular so we should
try to sound like them and maybe we
could be popular too you know
um I hate all that [__] that's why music
to me
now is garbage I don't listen to
anything new I haven't listened to
anything new in years you know uh
just all sounds the same we go on tour
we play with four or five bands every
night
they all sound the same they're always a
hardcore or metal
there's no like real rock and roll you
know where we're the slowest band on
stage every night
but you know what we get we get the most
people
dancing and
getting involved so you know it doesn't
matter how fast you are doesn't matter
how great you are if you're just gonna
sound like everybody else
and you're going to get lost in the
shuffle I mean we play with bands every
night that can play rings around us
[__] rings around us they can you
know wow great
yeah
doesn't mean [__]
if you don't have a good song to go with
it
you can play your ass off and I mean
you'd be a great guitar player but
if you're not in a good van this has
good songs that people want to hear
nobody gives a [__] you know
I see you wearing Charles Manson pants
yeah I got some Charlie pants I'm a
Charlie fan I guess and then you're also
wearing a monkey's t-shirt I am yes tell
me about the monkeys well the monkeys I
mean besides the Beatles the monkeys
were like it for us back in the
60s you know we love the [__] monkeys
we would skip school
to watch the monkeys because the monkeys
had a show The Beatles had a cartoon and
the monkeys had a show and uh hey hey
with the monkeys people say we monkey
around right we love the monkeys we've
we uh I had
a wooden guitar
with rubber bands on it and I would
strum that and pretend that I was like
[__] Mike nesmus you know and my
brother was was a drummer so of course
he loved Mickey dolins right and uh we
both thought Davy Jones was [__] lame
because he was so [__] pretty and all
the girls liked him so we were like he's
[__] gay but you know whatever
but yeah we love the monkeys I I still
have uh monkeys uh
CDs in my collection today I love them I
used to listen to them who are some of
your favorite bands from
the past few decades some of my favorite
bands uh the Ramones obviously
very big influence on us
The Dead Boys are one of my favorites I
love the New York Dolls I love the
Stooges and the MC5 and uh
a lot of uh a lot of That 70s
Johnny Saunders I loved him he was great
yeah a lot of 70 stuff I loved Led
Zeppelin In the Beginning their first
couple records were great
uh
and I love a lot of 60s music I was just
watching a
couple I guess it was one video it's a
compilation of
uh clips of
uh the night that Zebulon Zeppelin went
to watch Elvis
do a show I forget where it was I think
it might have been
I'd have been up in Canada or something
but whatever Zeppelin went to see Elvis
wow yeah
and they got to meet him after the show
and Elvis came around and to hear Robert
Plant talk about
what it was like to hang with Elvis I'm
sure like two hours yeah it's fast
fascinating that's pretty great it's
really you know it's it's a really great
thing
when
you can interact with artists and
musicians and people like that that have
influenced you uh uh I get a lot of that
nowadays because of the internet you
know and I'm out there and you know
people will message me and go are you
really Merle Allen
am I really talking to you I can't
believe I'm talking you know and I mean
it's I it's it's really cool
to be a like a part of something like
that because when we were kids I would
have given my [__] left nut to
[__] you know uh interact with Johnny
Ramone or or any of the people that we
were influenced by you know and nowadays
you can just
talk to people on on the internet you
know
and it's funny because a lot of times
they just don't they don't really think
it's you you know I've had people on my
GG page that go well I'm not buying
anything from you because I don't know
that that's really you and I go well
[__] you then I don't give a [__] I
don't need your [__] money anyway
so
but what's your biggest regret in your
life uh my biggest regret
probably leaving the only good women
that I've ever had in my life
that's probably my biggest regret was
you know I've had a couple of really
great women in my life and I've totally
[__] it up every single time you know
you're not the only one yeah you know I
mean but other than that I mean
I can't say I really have any regrets
when it comes to music because I feel
that I've been blessed and that
I feel that like the dream that I had
when I was a kid living in that Log
Cabin
and seeing where I've ended up today
I've never in a million years would have
dreamed that I would have done as many
things as I've done
in my life is that what you're proudest
of in your life yeah yeah absolutely
because because in my yearbook I my my
goal was to travel that was my goal in
life was to travel then once I got in a
band I wanted to travel with my band I
didn't want to just be a local band you
know and
the fact that we've traveled all over
this country more times than I can even
tell you we've been to Europe three
times we've been to Australia
we've played all over the world you know
and it's it's been a great experience
and I wouldn't I wouldn't trade my life
for anything you know I mean I you know
yeah there's a lot a lot of bands that
are a lot more popular that have done a
hell of a lot more but I'm grateful for
what I've got and the fact that I've
just even been able to do what I've done
for the last 30 years I think art
enrichens a person's life more than
anything even more than relationships
absolutely yeah because you can always
rely on that and if you had art and a
good relationship which I've had twice
in my life me too and I totally
jerked it off and [__] it up every
time but but it seems like at least with
me the uh
the art is something I never mess with I
never destroy that nope nope that's the
one the one great thing that's always
there it's the one thing that you you
know no matter what goes wrong or how
much your day is [__] up or your you
know this that and the other it's like
you know what
in another month I'm going to be going
on tour I'm going to be in a van with my
guys and we're going to be having a time
of our life you know
yeah always makes your life better yeah
absolutely yeah or just music in general
you know I don't know how people live
without music I mean I get up in the
morning I've got music playing all
[__] day long I'm playing my guitar
I'm playing my bass I'm listening to
music uh it's just
so I was there you know
have you been in several bands some with
Gigi some without or
were the were the experiences you had
touring with a band that was not
including Gigi less
satisfying less less interesting less
fun than uh the ones with them
well I mean the only band that I've ever
been with that toyed was the murder
jockeys so
post Gigi uh
you know in some ways
more fun because I had less
responsibility even though I still have
a lot of responsibility I'm still in
charge of a lot that goes on I book our
tours I collect our money I take care of
[__] Here There and Everywhere but it's
not nearly as taxing as it was with Gigi
uh excitement level of course there will
never be an excitement level uh that
could surpass being playing with my
brother that's goes without saying I
don't even think we even have to say
that
but uh
it's it's oh it's
I guess in a way it's more rewarding
today because
we've finally broke through
the
shadow of my brother which we've always
had on us and we always will have it on
us and that's fine I accept that no
problem but
when we reformed the band
in 2003
I had this idea in 2003 to put the band
back together
because it was Gigi's 10-year
anniversary
so
I recruited the original guys
and we recruited Jeff Clayton from
anti-scene who sang with us in the 90s
for the one tour we did with him after
my brother died and uh
we got the jabbers which was Gigi's
first band and we
decided we would play like four or five
shows on the East Coast we would go up
to New Hampshire where he was buried we
would play a show in Littleton New
Hampshire we'd go to the grave and hang
out and we had a big crowd of people the
first for the 10-year anniversary
and it was us in the jabbers and a
couple of the local bands and we played
New Hampshire we played in Providence we
played in Boston we played in New York
City
and uh I think we played another show
upstate news so we did like four or five
shows and uh I just figured that would
be like a okay we did the 10-year
anniversary right that'll be the end
well
with the internet
of course I I
had started to get on the internet and
was finally
online and once we did that tour
we started getting responses from people
that wanted us to come out and do
another tour
so
then we
in 2004
we recruited
JB Beverly who was our singer in 1998 to
1999. JB was our singer I met JB at one
of our shows in the DC area
in about 96 and we became friends he was
a young kid and uh
he sang with us right up until 1999 when
we ended the band
and then he went missing in action and
that was the end so so he toured with us
in 2004
and 2005. we got to go to Europe for the
first time
and that was a really a really great
experience because we never played
outside the USA so didn't really know
what to expect and you get over into
some of these countries where you know
you got these big [__] Viking guys
right and they come up to you and they
grab you and murder that in we love you
and they pick you up and they [__]
bear hugging you so you can hardly
breathe right you know like dude [__]
put me down you know it's like uh so it
was it was it was really cool to see
like how many fans we had in Europe I
mean I knew we had a lot of fans there
but we never had a chance to go there
you know so
uh so we did that for the first time
which was really great and then in 2006
uh
JB left the band
in the meantime our original guitar
player left the band and Scotty wood
joined on guitar
and in 2006
um
another one of our singers from the 90s
came along
which was Francis casimiglio
AKA FC murder I call him Franny
AKA Sonny Harlan AKA Dwayne rollick I
think he goes by Dwayne Rolex right now
but
anyway he came back on board as our
singer now
Francis
I met Francis
at a murder junkie show
in New York City
July
1996. we were playing a club called the
pyramid
it was like one of the only venues in
New York that would book us at that
point still you know uh and junkie Mike
was singing with us still Mike denied
um and
Francis drove six hours from weedsville
Pennsylvania some bum [__] hick bum [__]
Hicktown in Pennsylvania six hours he
drove to come see us play he's 22 years
old
big fan so we're on stage
getting ready to play
no mic denied Mike denied has left the
building well Mike denied was down on
the Lower East Side trying to buy drugs
because
he was a junkie so we had no singer
so I was like all right well we're going
to start the set and if anybody from the
audience wants to come up and sing a
song I figured we'd piece the set
together with you know getting somebody
from the crowd to sing a song that they
knew or whatever right
Francis FC murder
hops up on stage
and
counts off pool a piss and we go into
pool of piss and this and he knew the
words to every [__] song we went
through eight songs with him
and he knew every word perfectly and
after the eighth song Mike denied comes
strolling into the venue right pushes
Francis off stage gets up on stage to
sing
I stopped the show and fired him on the
spot in front of everybody in the crowd
so that was the end of Mike denied
and the beginning of Francis FC murder
now FC murder to me is my most valuable
player in the murder jockeys he's come
and gone
several times you know from singing he
now is our guitar player
so so we went back to Europe with FC
murder singing and
Scotty Hollywood on guitar I'm trying to
remember all this okay and then we came
back from that tour
and
had a call
from Hank Williams III
now I don't know
how too many of you out there don't know
who Hank Williams III is uh
Hank Jr was his dad Hank senior was his
granddad
um
he called and offered us a seven week
tour
ing Hank 3.
so
I met Hank 3 in 2002
at a venue in Clifton New Jersey called
connections he was playing a show and
some of my friends were like hey do you
know Hank Williams III his name is
Shelton Shelton Hank Williams III so did
you know Shelton was playing uh
connections tonight I'm like [__] no I
didn't even know there was a shout I
don't know who the hell he was you know
I didn't know I wasn't following what he
was doing right so I go to the show
thinking to myself well I want to meet
him you know I mean
I didn't really know what he was doing
but I got to the show and blew me away I
was so in love with what he was doing it
was like country
but Outlaw like kick your ass like [__]
you drugs drinking women you know the
whole [__] everything you know uh and
I was just wow this is [__] fantastic
it was country old school
fast and then after the country set he
would do like a full-on [__] metal
set it was [__] insane man it was it
was like I had never seen anything like
that so
the show's over I'm like
I want to meet him right so I'm going to
the tour bus right knocking on the door
kind of sheepishly like okay open the
[__] door JB Beverly our singer is
standing in the doorway and I'm like
what the [__] five minutes later I'm on
the back of the bus hanging out with
[__] Shelton
and we became fast friends and I started
going to shows and hanging out with the
band and they were all just like super
[__] cool they were fans and they
became friends you know and so when I
got that call I was like holy
seven weeks on the road with Hank three
playing in front of big crowds every
night
so my predicament was
I had seven weeks to fill
and I didn't have a [__] singer
so what I had to do was piece together
two singers
luckily
Jeff Clayton again from anti-scene who
has come through
several times for me in the past and uh
good friend and fan
so Jeff decided he would do the first
like three or four weeks three and a
half weeks or whatever and then JV
Beverly came in met up with us in Vegas
and uh continued and we finished the
tour we did seven weeks we got to play
The Roxy we got to play the [__]
Fillmore we got to play all the House of
Blues we got to play all of these like
legendary [__] venues all over the
[__] Country Places I'd never even
been to let alone perform at you know so
uh it was uh
it was a really probably one of the most
fun tours I've ever done in my life for
sure for sure so then okay 2007 comes
along
and
finally
we've got the singer
that we are looking for
Paul calangerino
PP duvet
auditioned for our band now I'd met Paul
during the 10-year anniversary tour when
his band he was in a band called they
hate us like a gutter punk band from
um
Putnam County New York yeah Upstate New
York and his band opened for us at one
of the upstate New York shows on the
anniversary tour so that's how I met
Paul and he came in and auditioned the
first time
was like okay but you need to do
something about your voice because he
doesn't he sang a little bit differently
with his other band I said you need to
put a little more you know growl into
your voice or whatever so he came back
for a second interview and
that
ended up being
the singer that we needed all the whole
time
so
he was the singer
Francis came back into the band in 2008
and
at that time
I knew we had like the best band post
Gigi
that we'd ever had
so
the question was now what are we going
to do so
I was
still living in New Jersey and I was
miserable as [__] so I had really no
motivation no uh
I was just like in a bad place I was
just basically going through the motion
with the songs that we'd been playing
because we hadn't done anything new in
so long because we just didn't have the
right mix of guys in the band you know
and when Paul joined the band he said I
just want to make sure if I'm going to
be in this band I want to at least
record one new record so
in 2010 I moved to California packed up
the U-Haul and drove across the country
and that was basically what I needed to
recharge myself and rejuvenate myself
and motivate myself and
that year we recorded our first album
an album called roadkiller and we
recorded that in 2010
and then in 2012 we recorded a killing
tradition and in 2013 we recorded
killing for Christ's sakes
and we maintained the same band for a 12
[__] years
so we went to Australia in 2010 High
tone entertainment and invited us to
come to Australia so we played there
and basically
just we'd been touring this country for
years and years and years and for you
[__] people living under a [__]
rock that didn't know we've been playing
we've been playing steadily since 200
[__] three where the [__] have you
been
so Gigi's been in your band on and off
you know you you started with the
jabbers is that right
Gigi yeah and then he left you guys
split up
well I was never
the jabbers were
Gigi's first band I had recorded the
first single with Gigi before there was
a band so the single that came out
um which was also on the first record
that we did that before there was even a
jabbers we were still living together in
New Hampshire I hadn't even moved to
Boston at that point so this would have
been 1977 that we recorded that single
and then when I moved to Boston to play
with Thrills uh Gigi had gotten married
that year and then moved to Manchester
and started the jabbers
so I was never actually in the jabbers
um
I was in the AIDS Brigade
but how did you reconnect
to be in a band with with your brother
again
um well off and on for years I mean we
would see you know we were close so no
matter what he was doing or what I was
doing we were always in tune with you
know well I and I was
obviously very envious and jealous and
like [__] man this guy's out doing what
I want to do you know and uh but I was
happy for him I was really glad that he
was
making a name for himself and uh so
um
we you know when Gigi wasn't doing
something I always wanted to get with
him and do something because I knew the
opportunity was only there
until something else came along
and if I didn't have it together like I
said earlier he would have gone with
whoever you know and so
um
back in Boston you know he was still
playing with the disappointments he was
still doing shows with the toilet
rockers and stuff like that but he would
always come back to Boston uh where I
was still living at the time in the 80s
and uh that's when we decided to do the
AIDS Brigade
and uh I mean we did one show we did a
single on Homestead records but
like I said and I think the last
interview we couldn't keep a band
together in Boston because
it was such a conservative
City and anybody that could really play
just didn't want nothing to do with us
you know and
everybody that sucked wanted to play
with us so you know we were fortunate
enough to get Chris Brokaw who was a
really good musician and he he but he
had a drug problem so that's probably
why he played with us at the time but he
was a great musician and and he's gone
on to
do solo stuff and he's taught all over
the world so he's been pretty successful
I guess but yeah we were only able to do
that one show and uh like pretty much
after that one show Gigi ended up
getting arrested that like a couple
months later or a month or so later and
that was the end and that's when I
decided to move to New York because I
knew
there would be no future for having a
band in in Boston anymore you know so
when I moved to New York
we put the band together and waited for
Gigi to get out of prison you know
how long was he in three years three
years and he passed away at what age uh
36 36 yeah
yeah
if you had your life to live all over
again what kind of things would you have
done differently
what would I have done different
um
uh probably would have moved to New York
sooner that's for sure I mean I had a
great time in Boston in the 70s and
early 80s
beg your pardon you feel like it held
you back
um maybe but uh
I don't know maybe not I mean but there
was a bunch of there were years between
when when Thrills broke up when I left
Thrills in 83 or so
um I mean I didn't really do too much I
was working a regular job you know I was
married to a [__] alcoholic
and working a regular job and I was it
was the most miserable three three
[__] years of my life
um because my brother would come to the
laundromat with a new record you know or
knew this and knew that and I'd be like
you [__] I mean you know
not really but I was you know I mean I
wanted to be doing that you know and I
was like married to a [__] drunken
[__] [__] and I was working two
[__] shitty jobs and I was miserable
you know so I I mean
if I could have moved to New York sooner
I probably would have the problem was I
didn't really have the money to do it at
the time you know so that was a problem
you know
and when I finally was able to get to
New York I had been married to uh my
second wife who family had money so they
kind of helped us get to New York and we
ended up in a nice doorman building you
know with an elevator the whole nine
yards man we were like we were like two
or three blocks from John Gotti's
[__] socialite ravenite called there
on Mulberry Street
you know
so I mean that was great I mean I loved
living in you know moving to New York in
1990 was amazing I mean it was still a
cool City
uh and
I was just happy to be there you know
what's your biggest fear now
um
I don't really have any big fears I
guess you're healthy I I think so
I don't know we'll see one day I haven't
been to a doctor in years so you know
I'll be one of those people that that
when I finally do go to the doctor he'll
tell me I got like three months to live
or something you know which would be
great I can take care of my Affairs get
my [__] funeral arrangements made and
leave my money to take my money with me
since I don't really have anybody to
leave my money to
you regret not having kids [__] no
that's [__] decision I ever made was
not having kids you know the best thing
I ever did was taking those [__] to
the [__] clinic man
yep best [__] thing I ever did I'd
[__] hate kids man
[__] hate him
I like Duke but he's about the only one
I like
yeah I mean kids kids hold you back I
mean kids and marriage I mean I've seen
it so many times it's like
I didn't want to go down that road
because I wanted to be free you know I
wanted to play music that was basically
all I wanted to do with my life so
having kids was not even in the equator
I wouldn't even be with a woman that
wanted kids
yeah
so you guys are going on tour again
it's coming up tell me tell me about
that yes okay so this year is Gigi's
30th death anniversary
so
we are going on tour for that reason
for sure but it's the
2023 scum [__] family tour GG Allen 30th
death anniversary uh
we are playing this is the murder
junkies murder junkies
um we have a new singer same band new
singer and we are playing all of the
Midwest the South and the East Coast we
will do an anniversary show up in New
Hampshire
at a place called The Dutch Treat which
is really the only place in New
Hampshire that will give us a show
anymore and the only reason we're able
to play at the Dutch Treat is because my
mom's boyfriend used to drink there
every day it's basically a restaurant
bar and it's in this small town in
Franconia which is seven miles away from
Littleton where my brother's buried so
we've been playing there we did the 15
the 20 the 25 year anniversary there and
we'll do the 30th year there and then we
will also play an anniversary show on
Gigi's actual death day in New York City
in Brooklyn
oh [__] I forget the name of the club
but if you uh
look on you got a website I I have my
Facebook page you can find my tour dates
there or I think they're actually pinned
to this last interview
that I did and maybe Mark will pin this
one as well I don't know but we'll find
out we'll see yeah excellent well Merle
thank you so much for giving us another
another talk my pleasure you're
fascinating thank you thank you very
much all right